[Music]
all right
what is he doing one more pocket
i am streaming exclusively on
twitch.tv okay no more losses today
nowhere else last game
guess what shroud's back and he's
putting twitch streamers
everywhere on notice so we have over 30
000 sub points
um just under 30 000 actual individual
subscriptions the rest are tier 3's tier
2's blah blah blah
pretty cool his first stream back was
just [ __ ] crazy
it had over 500 000 viewers at its peak
and he got 22 000 twitch subs in just
two hours
what's it at 22 000.
i called it oh my god how long have you
been live for like
two hours oh just about 30 more seconds
oh my god but to understand why shroudy
rowdy is back on twitch
we have to rewind almost a year to when
he left the website initially
and i know what you're thinking we've
done the mixer thing a hundred times on
this channel
i promise for your sanity and mine we're
gonna make it quick
first ninja leaves twitch for mixer i
will be streaming exclusively on mixer
a few months later shroud follows i'm
making moves
then panic takes over the streaming
community and no one knows who's going
to leave next
who knows who's next bro but nothing
really happens
twitch is fine and people still don't
care about mixer viewers on twitch are
literally too lazy to switch
channel from channel 41 to channel 2.
fast forward to june 2020 and
bye bye mixer's gone big oops all around
oh no and then ninja and shroud became
very very rich free agents
mixer's closing left the internet
wondering what
shroud and ninja were going to do next
my
sources tell me that facebook
apparently made an insane offer at
almost
double of what mixer paid
for ninja and shroud and loaded the
agency that represents
um ninja and shroud said no if this is
correct
somewhere of like 60 million dollars for
ninja
and 20 30 million dollars for shroud
and they said no so that they are free
to go back but while ninja tested the
waters
streaming on both twitch and youtube
shroud disappeared taking a months long
break from the internet
had a nice uh had a nice 40 something
day break
dude i've never played so little games
in my life over my break
it was it was nice honestly i'm not
gonna lie it was nice i think it was
needed
but when shroud returned he gave
everyone the announcement
they've been waiting for
the twitch shroud returned to was a land
of warring kingdoms
between xqc and the xqclers
[Applause]
summit and the 1g squad
[Music]
[Applause]
and nick merks and the m fam quest for
the crown
had been raging
and it's a crown that shroud has a good
chance to reclaim
already in his first week back the dudes
at the top of twitch viewership
look at all of these twitch primes damn
it feels good to say that again
twitch prime
it may have been almost a year since he
left twitch but
he's still the same old shroud well
except for that interesting choice of
facial hair
also known as the uncle shroud goatee
i'm an old man
you can call me uncle shroud if you want
despite piecing off to a smaller
platform for nearly a year
shroud's still as relevant as ever and
watching him on twitch
just feels natural what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]
you